this meeting confirms our common
determination to build on our
partnership and go towards an even
stronger and deeper and more political
partnership and friendship between both
continents we focused in particular on
three main areas of cooperation first
one is peace security and governance
this remains the central pillar of our
partnership coming to the second issue
we tackle today with our ministers we
have faced we have discussed together
the issue related to trade and
investment continental economic
integration third but not least at all
we agreed to work to promote cooperation
among us on the global scene the African
Union and the European Union are
collectively a force that works to shape
the global agenda and to strengthen and
support effective of the larger ISM most
importantly we have agreed to strengthen
the AU EU continent to continent
Partnership post-2020 backed by
commitments on both sides and
appropriate instruments and frameworks
this is critical for Africa it is
important for Europe it's important that
both of us these both continents invest
in the youth deal with the challenges of
climate change confront together the
current change challenge of migration
and return growth and prosperity to our
continents we also discussed today the
other many achievements that we have
made in the continent including the
launching of this continent on free
trade and many other opportunities
allowing our European friends who
believe in the future of the continent
to come and invest and be with us in in
in fostering this Africa we want but
also the European we want